so it started with a hilariously awkward
picture of John Green pretending to
write in the most uncomfortable position
possible a photo that was taken for an
article about him in The Hollywood
Reporter so congratulations for that
John Doe my girlfriend Emily thought
that it would be funny for me to copy
his pose in our own picture I put it on
the internet with the hashtag johning
and I guess that Twitter must have been
having a particularly slow week because
for some reason it became its own little
meme well I am definitely proud I think
of the success of joining I'm less happy
about the fact that I think it is the
most successful project I've worked on
in let's just say quite a while the
problem that I've been experiencing is
that all of the ideas that I've had
recently that I actually like have been
for things that I just do not have the
skills required to actually accomplish
for example my ideas for a website and
for a video game as much as I do
definitely feel like just some dumb kid
who doesn't understand how ambitious and
difficult his cool ideas actually are I
still feel like I have to try and so I'm
gonna pitch my ideas to you because I
don't know how else to do firstly the
websites so just like everyone else who
uses YouTube regularly I have a bit of a
love-hate relationship with the website
and more than anything I'd really like
them to have some proper competition in
the hopes that it might encourage them
to up their game a bit but obviously you
can't make just another video streaming
website and hope it does as well as
YouTube there has to be something
different enough about it to justify it
existing and so I asked myself what is
the one thing that I would change about
YouTube if I could and I decided that I
would want to get rid of you counts
instead the videos on my hypothetical
website would be ranked based on overall
engagement so you would actually be
worth the least because although you are
engaging with the content it's only in a
very passive way and the longer you
watch something the more that view would
be worth because the more engaged you
are if you click like on a video that
would be worth more engagement than a
view because the video is actually
encouraging you to take some kind of
action if you share a video that's worth
more engagement if you leave a comment
the longer and better written your
comment is the more engagement it's
worth and if you decide to leave a video
response that's the most engaged you can
be because you've actually been
encouraged to create something new based
on what you've seen and so all of that
data would be put through an algorithm
that would come up with an engagement
rating for a video and that
number would be the big one that would
appear underneath the video as opposed
to a few count I think that to start
with it would probably have to just rank
existing online videos as opposed to
hosting all of its own stuff but yeah
that's my website now the video game so
you play as a ghost who died hundreds of
years ago in this big old warehouse
building and it's been so long now since
you died that two things have happened
you've completely forgotten about your
past so you can't remember what your
unfinished business is and the warehouse
in which you've died has since been
converted into a block of trendy
apartments and so the gameplay would be
that you'd be able to wander freely
around all of these people's apartments
observe their lives and then decide
taunt them however you like for example
you're wandering around you discover
somebody trying to break into someone
else's apartment you scare the hell out
of them they run away or you could
wander into someone's apartment observe
them discover that they are
procrastinating from putting up their
shelves you can wait until they're gone
and then you can haunt them nicely by
putting their shelves up even as someone
who's only ever played video games I can
see a lot of potential issues in the
idea but I still really like the general
concept of like a ghost simulator and it
feels like the kind of story that would
just work best if told through a
videogame because for whatever reason so
if there is anybody out there who thinks
they'd be able to help me make these
ideas a reality please do get in touch
and if there's anybody out there who
wants to steal these ideas I guess I'm
making it pretty easy for you to do that
so I will ask you politely not to
because like I said I don't know else to
do here thank you very much for your
potential help and let's hope the ideas
don't die with this video cuz that'd be
sad goodbye you've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching Charlie is
so cool like which makes you like cool a
lot of you probably noticed this already
but I will now confer me for you I
bought the lights I'm not sorry thank
you for watching if you'd like to watch
my previous video you have 10 seconds to
find it good luck
it was here all along and you're
terrible at finding things
sorry I mean deal with it